(Musique)
9 millions d'abonnés mon pote
Yes, un maximum d'argent et de biatches
c'est énorme ça change rien à ma vie putain.
Je sais pas si vous souvenez mais les 2 dernières années, j'avais fêté l'anniversaire de la chaîne qui est le 3 mars en vous rencontrant sur Omegle.
Cette année, en 2017, je ne l'ai pas fait pour les 6 ans de la chaîne.
J'avais déjà fait 2 fois la même chose, à savoir jeter des confettis, ouvrir des bouteilles de Champomy et faire la fête.
J'avais pas envie de refaire la même chose !
Mais là, hier, j'ai eu une idée, je me suis dit, putain mais attends...
Pour les 9 millions, est-ce que ce serait pas drôle de refaire ça mais de vous pranker !
Ooh, putain, je fais une prank sur YouTube, ça y est ce jour est arrivé, oooooh !
Manquerait plus qu'elle soit fake et on aurait touché le fond, putain !
Je vais vous annoncer sur Twitter que je vous attends sur Omegle...
Sauf que quand vous allez tomber sur moi, je ne serai pas Squeezie...
Je serai un... remake nul de Justin Bieber.
Là, vous vous dites que c'est une idée de merde parce qu'on me reconnait grâce au fond...
et vous avez 100% raison mais grâce à cet outil,
nous allons pouvoir faire des choses formidables.
La pire chose, je vais vous dire, c'est que les gens croient vraiment que c'est quelqu'un d'autre et me next direct.
Et là, la vidéo serait vraiment nulle.
C'est parti !!
(musique)
Elle m'a nexté, elle m'a nexté !! Des barres !
Heeeeey... oh, merde ! (rire)
(musique)
Mais, putain, ils me zappent tous... alors qu'on a mis le même tag ! C'est génial !
Mec, je suis trop bien camouflé ! Mon montage, il marche trop bien, c'est génial !
Ils me zappent, ils ne savent pas que c'est moi, mec, c'est génial !
(musique)
Abonnée : c'est pas Squeezie, non plus ?! Ah...
Abonnée : En vrai, c'est un fond vert de ... (rires)
(rires)
Oooh, comment, ça va mon gars ? Ca a bien marché ou pas le fond vert ?
Abonné : Ah, oui, c'est magnifique, le fond vert !
Mais mec, tout le monde me zappe parce qu'ils croient que c'est pas moi !
Abonné : J't'ai reconnu à la barbe en fait ! (rire)
Ah, c'est un vrai, ça c'est un vrai, hein !
(musique)
Surpriiiiiise !
Nan... ?
Bon bah, ok...
Putain, mec, la personne d'avant n'a tellement pas réagi... je... ça m'a fait mal au coeur.
Elle m'a laissé bider et elle m'a nexté immédiatement, c'était terrible !
(musique)
Surpriiiiiise !
(Rires)
Abonnée : Mon fils va être fou que je te parle
(Micro-Patate) Abonnée : Mais c'est l’apocalypse la en Bretagne, c'est un truc de fou !
Abonnée : Tu veux voir le ciel dehors, c'est tout noir et jaune ...
Whaaa ?!
Montre, tu peut me montrer ou pas ou c'est chaud ?
Oh je sens que le wifi va couper la,  on a brusquer le pc la
(Bruit de micro patate mourant)
Et voila, j'ai eu la pire idée du monde ....
Abonnée : Nan attend, j'suis sur c'est un truc, un truc fake ...
AHAH ! Mais tu vois bien que c'est moi putain !
Abonnée : J'adore tes cheveux !
Et tu trouve pas que je ressemble un peu a Squeezie ? ;)
Regarde, sans les lunettes !
Présentatrice des Oscars (en anglais) : Et l'Oscar revient à .....
Voix robotique : Cet homme !
(Musique)
Ca va ou quoi ? :D
Tu fais quoi en habits militaire ?
Abonné militaire : Je suis au travail, j'suis au travail !
C'est vrai ?! C'est la petite pause du midi ?
Abonné militaire : baeuh c'est la petite pause de l'aprem entière parce que rien à faire !
Et bah bon courage pour le taf mec !
Veille sur le pays ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Abonné : Oh, lol, je suis tombé sur un fake de SQUEEZIE
Abonné : Oh, lol, je suis tombé sur un fake de SQUEEZIE..
Abonné : "Non, c'est pas un fake ça !"
Squeezie : "ça va ou quoi ?"
Abonné : "Oh putain j'ai ouvert 4 pages omegle pour te trouver"
Squeezie : "Bah mec t'as bien fait, ça a porté ces fruits !"
Squeezie : "Pleins de bonnes choses, merci pour les 9 millions. Et bah voilà bientôt sur YouTube !"
Squeezie : "Apparement je suis un fake, un fake de moi même !"
"C'est tellement horrible"
Squeezie : "Eh oh... arrête de fumer déjà !"
Abonné : "C'est pas Squeezie ? T'es sérieux ?"
Squeezie : "Elle était bien ma prank ou pas ?"
Abonné : "C'est génial"
Abonné : "Je pensais pas tomber sur toi et maintenant que je te parle, j'ai le coeur qui bat à 1000 à l'heure !"
Squeezie : "Tu me fais le même effet, t'es trop beau gosse, ça me touche"
Abonné : "C'est vrai le corps de lâche moi c'est comme toi, c'est pareil"
"On connaît bien"
Abonné : "J'ai vraiment un truc qui est toujours..."
"Le soir quand je rentre je vais aux toilettes et c'est à ce moment que je regarde tes vidéos"
Squeezie : "C'est ça ou la notice du truc qui sent bon donc j'avoue je préfère les vidéos"
Abonné : "Non, t'es sérieux ?
Squeezie : "Oui je suis sérieux"
Abonné : "Déjà bravo pour les 9 millions frère
Squeezie : "Merci mec, c'est la fête, je fais la fête seul dans mon bureau"
"Tu sais quoi ?Tu es l'heureux gagnant d'un pain au chocolat"
"Non ? Ok, t'es plutôt pain aux raisins, c'est pas grave"
Squeezie : "Romain !!! Mec !"
Romain : "Bébé ! Mon amour ! Je t'aime !"
Squeezie : "Je tombe sur un pote à moi, c'est génial !"
Romain "On se fait un petit Fortnite mon gars, hein ?"
Squeezie : "Allez, ce soir on se fait un petit Fortnite mais laisse la place aux abonnés !"
"Qu'est-ce que tu viens prendre la place d'un abonné ici ?"
Romain : "Je voulais te dire que je t'aime."
Squeezie : "Vas-y à toute vieux"
Squeezie : "Et bim, c'est vraiment moi, tu t'y attendais pas"
Abonnée : "Ben non"
Squeezie : "Ben si"
Abonée : "Non"
Squeezie : "Je peux insister quand même, si"
"Ecoute je voulais te remercier pour les 9 millions d'abonnés"
"C'est hyper sympa, merci de regarder les vidéos, c'est très gentil, et puis j'espère que ça continuera à te plaire"
"Et je te dis à bientôt sur YouTube"
Squeezie : "Ciao"
Abonnée : "Bisous"
Abonnée : "Mais c'est vraiment Squeezie ou pas là ?"
Squeezie : "Regarde, attention, effets spéciaux"
Abonnée : "Je sais pas si c'est vrai ou si c'est un fake maintenant"
Squeezie : "T'as vu ? Les effets spéciaux sont tellement puissants que les gens croient que c'est un fake tu te rends compte ?
Abonnée : "Pas mal la déco"
Squeezie : "Ca gaze ?"
(Rires)
Squeezie : "Pas mal la déco"
Abonnés : "On vient de Belgique"
Squeezie : " Gros big-up à la Belgique, aux belges, merci beaucoup pour les 9 millions et à bientôt sur Youtube"
Abonnés : "Merci, on t'aime trop, bisous
Squeezie : "Avant de partir tu veux les réfs ou pas de la déco ?"
Squeezie : "T'en avais rien à foutre de mon effet spectaculaire"
Abonnée : "Demain je passe mon permis pour la 4ème fois"
Squeezie : "4ème fois !? J'espère de tout cœur que ça ira"
"Et si ça va pas je te conseille la trotinette électrique, c'est vraiment pas mal, ça va juste un peu moins vite"
Squeezie : "Et il essuie la casserole"
Abonné : "Ah t'es là toi !"
Squeezie : "Eh baisse d'un ton, baisse d'un ton"
Squeezie : "Il fait quoi ? Qu'est-ce que tu fais là t'essuies la casserole de tes pâtes ?"
Abonné : "Non c'était pas des pâtes c'était de la vaisselle d'hier et y avait du riz"
Squeezie : "J'avais une chance sur deux on va pas se mentir"
"Ecoute mec, merci pour les 9 millions d'abonnés, j'espère que ton repas d'hier était délicieux"
"Et puis je te dis à bientôt sur YouTube"
Abonné : "Merci à toi aussi"
Squeezie : "Merci mec"
Squeezie : "Il était génial, cet homme a refait ma journée"
Squeezie : "Il est tombé de sa chaise ! Bah mec merci, pour les 9 millions"
Abonné : "Merci à toi de faire autant de bon contenu"
Squeezie : "Merci beaucoup mec et ton décor est très stylé, voilà je suis jaloux, un vrai otaku"
Abonnée : "Non, c'est pas Lucas"
Squeezie : "Mais bien sûr que c'est Lucas regarde ça bim je t'ai pranké"
Abonnée : "J'y crois pas j'ai l'impressionn que c'est un montage"
Squeezie : "C'est peut-être un montage"
Abonnée : "Nooonn..."
Squeezie : "Je suis un montage désolé"
Abonnée : "Arrêêête"
Abonnée : "T'es pas gentil genre j'ai vraiment cru que c'était un montage"
Squeezie : "Pardon je m'en veux putain excuse-moi"
Abonnées : "Salut !!!"
(Cris)
Abonnée : "Mais arrête"
Squeezie : "Attends (x3), vous êtes sérieuses de faire votre pub là comme ça ?"
Abonnée : "Ouiiii, attends mais j'ai gagné plein d'abonnés avec ça"
Squeezie : "Bon, les filles j'avoue je suis assez pressé, mais en tout cas merci pour les 9 millions"
Squeezie : "Ciao, bisous"
Abonnées : "Merci, ciao"
Squeezie : "Ooooh, elle est blasée"
Abonnée : "Ouuuiiii"
Squeezie : "Ah elle est plus blasée d'un coup"
Abonnée : "Depuis une heure je te cherche, en plus sans faire exprès je t'ai nexté, j'étais dégoûtée"
Squeezie : "Y a tellement de gens qui m'ont zappé, j'ai pas le temps de me montrer ils zappent parce que c'est un faux décor"
Abonnée : "Sérieux ?"
Squeezie : "Ouais regarde"
Abonnée : "Ah mais je suis..."
Squeezie : "Bon bah merci pour les 9 millions, plein de bonnes choses et puis à bientôt sur YouTube"
Abonnée : "A bientôt"
Squeezie : "Oh elle m'a zappé putain j'ai même pas eu le temps de me cacher"
Abonné : "Eh !"
Squeezie : "Ouais ?"
Abonné : "Ouaiiiiiissss !"
Squeezie : "Excellent"
Squeezie : "Tu joues en même temps que t'attends, tranquille, j'ai vu que t'avais une manette de PS4"
Abonné : "Ouais, je suis en train de faire du Final Fantasy là, je suis en train de pêcher là"
Squeezie : "Ambiance posée"
Squeezie : "A bientôt poto"
Abonné :"Bonne chance, remets bien ton fond vert"
(Rires)
Squeezie : "Ouais ! Ciao mec"
Abonné : "Quelqu'un ? Allô ?"
(Cri de surprise)
Abonné : "Putain , Squeezie !"
Squeezie : "Sympa ton pull Laink et Terracid"
Abonnée : "Merci"
Abonné : "Squeezie ?"
Squeezie : "Ca va ou quoi ?"
Abonné : "C'est vraiment toi ?"
Abonné : "Félicitations, bientôt pour tes 9 millions"
Squeezie : "Merci à toi, je suis là pour vous remercier donc mille mercis et puis plein de bonnes choses pour toi"
Abonné : "Moi j'espère pouvoir me lancer bientôt sur YouTube"
Squeezie : "Et bah lance-toi et fais-toi kiffer, fais-toi plaisir, amuse-toi, c'est l'important"
Squeezie : "A bientôt poto, ciao"
Abonné : "Merci, à bientôt"
(Musique)
Squeezie : "Très bien la musique là !"
Abonné : "Ah c'est la vie"
Squeezie : "Le bon Patoche. Merci beaucoup pour les 9 millions, merci à toi et puis à bientôt sur YouTube pour écouter du Patrick Sébastien"
(Musique de Patrick Sébastien)
Squeezie : "Cool ou pas cette petite entrée ?"
Abonné : "Elle est ma-gni-fique"
Squeezie : "N'est-ce pas ?"
Abonné : "Une demi-heure que je te cherche, j'ai 20 ans aujourd'hui, j'espérais te trouver et là c'est le plus beau cadeau que je peux avoir"
Squeezie : "Alors là mec, joyeux anniversaire !"
Abonné : "Attends, est-ce que ce serait pas ce décor ?"
Squeezie : "Ouais qu'est-ce que t'as ?"
(Rires)
Abonné : "Oh putain ouii !"
Squeezie : "Merci pour les 9 millions"
Abonné : "Mais je t'en prie, mais c'est grâce à toi, on n'aurait pas pu en arriver là sans toi"
Squeezie : "Arrête (x3), moi je peux pas m'abonner à ma propre chaîne, donc c'est grâce à toi"
Squeezie (chantant) : "La, la laaaa"
Abonnée : "Tu sais que ça fait 5 fois que je tombe sur toi en fait, c'est abusé"
Squeezie : "Ne me zappe plus jamais comme ça, attention"
Abonnée : "Mais je m'excuse"
(Musique)
Squeezie : "Ca va ou quoi ?"
Abonnés :"Oh géniaaal !"
Abonné : "Mec continue ce que tu fais t'es ouf, t'es génial, je suis trop, oh putain je suis content !"
Squeezie : "Merci mec, à bientôt les gars ciao"
Squeezie : "Et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu"
"Merci pour les 9 millions d'abonnés, désolé à ceux qui étaient pas disponibles au moment où j'ai fait ce petit truc Omegle"
"Désolé à ceux qui étaient disponibles et qui sont pas tombés sur moi, c'est la loi du hasard finalement"
"Je pouvais pas tous vous voir sur Omegle c'était impossible mais j'en ai fait un maximum, ça fait 2 heures, je suis mort"
"La prochaine étape c'est les 10 millions, l'étape à laquelle tu rajoutes un chiffre au nombre, c'est assez ouf"
"Après c'est que des chiffres en vrai on s'en fout un peu mais c'est quand même représentatif du succès au nom de quelque chose,"
donc je peux pas ignorer ça. Merci du fond du cœur, merci à tous ceux que j'ai croisé, qui m'ont bien fait marrer et puis à très vite sur YouTube"
"Au revoir"
(Musique)